this video was made possible by better
help.com / Pakman where you can get
affordable online access to a licensed
therapist through text phone and video
chat
just click the link under this video
I've got some interesting media news and
it's about online encyclopedia Wikipedia
which announced yesterday that they are
banning Breitbart and Alex Jones's
website info wars as sources of facts
and the Conservatives are furious about
this but I think that this makes a lot
of sense and I'm going to explain to you
why this was a decision made by
Wikipedia editors who presumably are of
all sorts of political stripes and
backgrounds and what they determined is
that Wikipedia articles for the purpose
of sourcing facts should not be using
info wars or Breitbart they are no
longer going to be allowed Wikipedia
previously decided that for example the
Daily Mail can't be used as a source of
facts on the English version of
Wikipedia I hate to break it to the
right-wingers that are furious about
this but this is not censorship this is
not bias and it's not controversial it's
not because Breitbart and info wars are
right-wing and I am left-wing and I want
a left-wing bias on Wikipedia that I
don't think Breitbart and info wars
should be used as sources of facts
left-wing website occupied Democrats is
also not allowed on Wikipedia as a
source of facts and I agree with that
decision they don't report news they
editorialize and do partisan opinion
stuff I like some of it
I dislike some of it but occupy
Democrats shouldn't be used as a source
of facts on Wikipedia Ross story is a
left-leaning website it also shouldn't
be a source of facts on Wikipedia they
aren't being censored Wikipedia is
merely saying they're not up to a
standard that we believe should be
adhered to for sources of fact and I
want to go further the david pakman show
shouldn't be cited as a source of facts
about for example the Cavanagh
hearings and what I mean by that is if
you go to the Brett Kavanaugh Wikipedia
page about sexual assault allegations if
I say in a video on my show that
Cavanaugh gave a 40 minute opening
statement the David Pakman show should
not be cited for that fact it should be
a c-span video of him actually giving a
40 minute opening statement it should be
an AP article explaining that he gave a
40 minute opening statement but it
shouldn't be the David Pakman show
because we are a news analysis and
commentary show we are cited on
Wikipedia in many places but as
citations for for example things that
guests have said during interviews right
if you go on Wikipedia and it says
during such-and-such interview on the
David Pakman show John Kerry said the
following and then there's a link to
John Kerry saying that on our show
that's a citation that makes sense for
opinion and analysis shows and websites
but citing the David Pakman show for
basic news reporting doesn't make sense
because that's not exactly what we do
I might restate and analyze something
reported by The Associated Press but I
am NOT a source of underlying facts and
even though Breitbart wants to be seen
as a source of underlying facts they
aren't they're a partisan commentary
website they often tout absolutely
ridiculous conspiracies period I don't
even think we have to argue about info
wars as a source of facts on Wikipedia
but this is not a free speech issue this
is not a censorship issue plain and
simple it's simply a determination made
by editors about the quality of
informant information that comes from
particular sources this would actually
be an indictment on Wikipedia's
credibility if Breitbart and Infowars
are allowed as a source of facts and the
fact that they've only just now been
banned sort of should make us question
what why was Wikipedia even allowing
them to begin with this should not be
controversial it is not a First
Amendment issue obviously since
Wikipedia is not the government and it's
also not a censorship issue if you
disagree with me okay if you think
that there is some reason why Breitbart
and Infowars should be allowed as
sources of facts on an encyclopedia like
Wikipedia let me know if if you believe
I am missing an argument explaining why
that is I do want to hear from you
you can email in use any of our social
media platforms and please make sure
that you are following the show on
Instagram we're on instagram at david
pakman show and I am on instagram at
David Pakman I hope you're following us
both quick break the conclusion to my
interview with economist Steve Keen is
coming up next and then more stories and
a lot of other news to get to